[Music]
one two
three four
one out of four children in europe lives
in poverty
or is at risk of poverty and social
exclusion
samuel does not have a home josephine
went to bed on an empty stomach last
night
christopher's parents cannot afford
medicine when he's sick
sophia's dad cannot pay for her school
supplies
lila's mom cannot afford to send her to
kindergarten
we must end child poverty in europe now
our real future lies in the hands and
dreams of children growing up
being the adults of tomorrow
this is why the socialists and democrats
propose the european child guarantee
the guarantee will provide decent
housing
adequate nutrition free quality health
free quality education and free quality
child
care for the children who need it most
imagine a europe where all people earn a
living wage
everyone can afford decent housing and
no child grows up in poverty
at the porto summit in may we lay the
foundations for the europe
we want to live in
we call on eu governments to bring our
initiative the child guarantee to life
and back it with ambitious national
plans and investments
let's end child poverty now for more
information
social rights dot eu